[Musik]
machtkampf um cdu-vorsitz die wahl wird
verschoben friedrich merz wittert einen
komplott masken pflicht bis weihnachten
in mehreren bundesländern beginnt wieder
die schule
die strengsten regeln hat
nordrhein-westfalen skifahren in der
pandemie österreich beginnt die saison
mit abstand und hygiene konzept
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am montag für den
sport ist heute sein fonds an meiner
seite auch von mir einen schönen guten
abend
corona bringt vieles durcheinander und
verzögert auch die wahl eines neuen
cdu-chefs und möglichen
kanzlerkandidaten
ursprünglich sollte die nachfolge für
annegret kramp karrenbauer ja im april
geklärt werden
doch wegen der pandemie wurde der
parteitag auf dezember verschoben jetzt
entschloss sich die cdu spitze auch von
diesem termin abstand zu nehmen
zwei der drei kandidaten finden das gut
nach armin laschet erklärte auch norbert
röttgen nur mit einer verschiebung werde
die cdu ihrer verantwortung in der
pandemie gerecht friedrich merz dagegen
beharrt auf einer entscheidung jetzt und
wettert gegen die parteispitze
stellt sich also die frage wem nützt und
wem schadet es wenn die partei bis zum
frühjahr wartet thomas reichert der
cdu-generalsekretär hat heute viel zu
erklären
der parteitag soll wegen corona
verschoben werden verschoben ist damit
auch die entscheidung im machtkampf um
den parteivorsitz
es geht also um viel mehr als termin
fragen die nun frühestens am 14
dezember entschieden werden unsere
hoffnung ist natürlich ein stück weit
dass wir am 14
mehr licht im dunkel dieser lage haben
und sagen können ja wohl entweder gibt
es dann die möglichkeit an präsenz
parteitag durchzuführen oder es gibt die
nicht ich hätte mir gewünscht dass wir
jetzt in einer anderen situation werden
dass wir jetzt um das ganz offen zu
sagen dass wir am vierten dezember einen
neuen cdu-vorsitzenden übrigens einen
ganzen neuen vorstand gewählt hätten
so aber bricht offener streit aus um
chefposten und verfahren fünf stunden
saß die parteispitze gestern mit den
drei kandidaten beisammen
am morgen danach wert hat friedrich merz
mit der verschiebung wolle man ihn der
in umfragen unter parteimitgliedern im
moment vorne liegt verhindern
es gibt beachtliche teile die verhindern
wollen dass ich parteivorsitzender werde
und damit wird jetzt auch dieser
parteitag verbunden märz will nun so
schnell als möglich einen digitalen
parteitag den er zuvor abgelehnt hat
laschet und röttgen dagegen scheinen zu
hoffen mit der verschiebung zeit zu
gewinnen um gegen märz aufzuholen es
gibt keinen grund weshalb dieser
parteitag nun ausgerechnet im dezember
stattfinden muss er kann auch wenige
wochen später wenn wir die pandemie
wieder im griff haben stattfinden
und deshalb muss politik vorbild sein
wir haben jetzt eine verfahrens
grundlage mit der wir die führungsfrage
in der union entscheiden können denn das
ist wichtig wir stehen vor einem ganz
wichtigen superwahljahres sorgt nun
dafür dass die machtfrage in der cdu
noch auf wochen ungeklärt bleibt und in
der partei der streit um den vorsitz
weiter eskaliert da ein ziemliches
dilemma für die cdu unter labbadia jetzt
brechen ja doch die grabenkämpfe voll
auf wie man eigentlich unbedingt
vermeiden wollte
und ja das hat man ja schon fast wieder
vergessen den richtungsstreit in der cdu
über den die vorige vorsitzende und aber
noch amtierende vorsitzende annegret
kramp karrenbauer gestolpert ist und an
dem sie gescheitert ist er wurde durch
die korona pandemie jetzt lange zeit
verdeckt und auch friedrich merz hat
sich im bisherigen wahlkampf eher
versöhnlich gezeigt umso erstaunlicher
ist der plötzliche kurswechsel den er da
vollzieht bisher hatte ausdrücklich
angela merkel und ihre bilanz gelobt was
ja vorher auch nicht selbstverständlich
für ihn gewesen ist und hat auch immer
wieder über versöhnung der partei
gesprochen das was er heute so von sich
gegeben hat das erinnert wieder an alte
die gegen uns parolen die aus seinem
umfeld auch 2018 schon zu vernehmen
gewesen waren also da auch wieder im
richtungsstreit die frage ist ob er sich
damit einen gefallen tut aber solange es
keinen cdu chef gibt kann ja auch die
kanzlerin nachfolge nicht geklärt werden
oder ja diese frage muss man tatsächlich
mit denken denn natürlich überlegt die
cdu auch mit welchem kanzlerkandidaten
sie am besten wahlen gewinnen kann und
da liegt in den umfragen nicht friedrich
merz vorne sondern jens spahn und markus
söder aktuell also zwei die bei der
bei der vorsitzenden frage überhaupt
nicht zur wahl stehen und das kann
natürlich einem friedrich merz nicht
gefallen der immer gesagt hat wenn er
vorsitzender wird dann will er auch
kanzlerkandidat werden dass es jetzt
mehr zeit gibt für solche gedanken
spielten ob man vielleicht mit einem
vorsitzenden und einem kanzlerkandidaten
getrennt zwei personen in den wahlkampf
geht das kann ihm nicht wirklich
gefallen vielen dank und energy nach
berlin
er wollte sich bei der nächsten
bundestagswahl zurückziehen
spd-politiker und bundestags
vizepräsident thomas oppermann nach 40
jahren in der politik freute er sich
offenbar schon auf die zeit danach
gestern abend wollte in der zdf in die
sendung berlin direkt schalten als ob er
man nur minuten vor dem auftritt in
göttingen zusammenbrach und wenig später
in der uniklinik starb ein schock für
alle die ihn kannten und schätzten
charmant fit einer mit humor ein
pragmatischer sozialdemokrat immer mit
eigener haltung und ein besonnener
streiter der sich zuletzt mehr rechte
des parlaments bei krone entscheidung
und wünschte jetzt rächt es sich dass
bei der vorbereitung auf die zweite
welle der bundestag außen vorgelassen
worden ist thomas oppermann es
plötzlicher tod lässt keinen platz mehr
für seinen plan mit 66 jahren noch mal
ein leben ohne bundestag anzufangen
sein tod ist nicht nur unter den
umständen tragisch sondern insbesondere
weil er erklärt hatte dass er jetzt
seine karriere als parlamentarier
beenden wird thomas oppermann
ehrgeizig aber teamspieler seit 1980 in
der spd jusos jurist und 1998 jüngster
minister im kabinett des damaligen
niedersächsischen ministerpräsidenten
gerhard schröder den menschen zugewandt
für der politik gemacht hat und auf die
erachtete bis zuletzt
und das macht seine bedeutung aus
im bundestag bündelte oppermann als
spd-fraktionsvorsitzender vier jahre
lang die gemeinsame politik der großen
koalition ein gewinnender mensch was
thomas oppermann auszeichnete war
besonders das was man vielleicht eine
freundliche demokratische
ernsthaftigkeit nennen kann seine stimme
wird dem parlament fehlen nicht nur der
spd
und jetzt zum thema corona in immer mehr
landkreisen in deutschland drohen
weitere beschränkungen
zwar meldete das robert koch institut
heute früh etwas weniger neuinfektionen
als zuletzt
8600 85 allerdings werden am wochenende
erfahrungsgemäß nicht alle neuen fälle
erfasst bundesweit liegt bei den sieben
tageswerten jetzt der kreis rottal inn
an der spitze gefolgt vom
berchtesgadener land und dem
niedersächsischen delmenhorst volker
wutschik ein neuer tag ein neuer hotspot
in bayern ist es nun der landkreis
rottal inn
der wert für neuansteckungen auf 100000
einwohner liegt jetzt bei 2 160,1 ab
morgen werden schulen und kitas
geschlossen veranstaltungen abgesagt die
gesundheitsämter am rande ihrer kräfte
uns ist es sehr wichtig dieses kontakt
nachverfolgen möglichst lange gut
aufrechterhalten zu können
und das ist auch das ziel aber wir
merken natürlich auch dass es da und
dort einfach grenzen gibt wenn die
zahlen sprunghaft steigen
anderer ort gleiches problem auch
delmenhorst bei bremen kämpft gegen hohe
corona zahlen masken pflicht kontrolle
da muss man als polizistin auch mit
beschimpfungen rechnen hier auftrumpfen
und so wilde sau spielen wollen wer
keine maske trägt muss hier mindestens
150 euro zahlen
denn delmenhorst es der sieben tage wert
bei den neuansteckungen bei 200 17,9
gelandet und das obwohl die stadt ein
ganzes maßnahmenpaket hat dazu zählen
neben der masken pflicht das verbot von
treffen mit mehr als zehn leuten eine
sperrstunde von 23 bis 6 uhr und keine
gottesdienste
doch die zahl der neuinfektionen bleibt
weiter hoch in berlin sagt
regierungssprecher seibert die lage sei
ernst die neue infektion hätten sich im
vergleich zur vorwoche nahezu verdoppelt
bundeskanzlerin merkel will sich bereits
am mittwoch bei einer video konferenz
mit den ministerpräsidenten über neue
maßnahmen verständigen zwei tage früher
als geplant nach zwei wochen
herbstferien gehen heute in einigen
bundesländern die schulen wieder los
fast überall unter verschärften corona
auflagen für nordrhein-westfalen zum
beispiel gilt masken pflicht auch im
unterricht ab der fünften klasse und
mindestens bis zu den weihnachtsferien
torge bode war an einer schule in
mönchengladbach erste stunde im
gymnasium am geroweiher einführung in
die neue hygiene-regeln auf dem gesamten
schulgelände muss eine mund nasen
bedeckung getragen werden auch während
des unterrichts die gefühle der
schülerinnen und schüler der achten
klasse dazu gemischt ich habe mich
ehrlich gesagt ziemlich geärgert weil
ich kriege ich auch wenn ich die maske
zu lange tragen ein bisschen
kopfschmerzen für mich war es eigentlich
nicht so schlimm welche maske wurde wo
immer trage fast ganz nrw ist
mittlerweile risikogebiet die maßnahmen
des schulministeriums kann der
schulleiter daher im prinzip
nachvollziehen allerdings auf der
anderen seite hätte ich mir aber auch
gewünscht dass man sie zunächst bis
mitte november ausspricht um dann die
lage noch einmal neu zu bewerten um
wirklich zu schauen inwiefern sind die
schulen an einer
weiteren steigenden zahl auch mit
beteiligt zusätzlich zu masken pflicht
muss alle 20 minuten gelüftet werden der
lehrergewerkschaft reicht das nicht die
klassenverbände müssten aber einer
bestimmten instanz zahl geteilt werden
um abstände einhalten zu können
so hatte es das robert koch institut
empfiehlt wir brauchen glaube ich
dringend wo wir jetzt so steigen die
zahlen haben auch wirklich einen
stufenplan der sagt eben angelehnt zum
beispiel anders was das rk ii empfiehlt
aber 35 plus eben mit maske im
unterricht bei 50plus ebenen halben
klassen
das ist hier nicht angedacht und das
fehlt eine teilung der klassen lehnt das
ministerium derzeit ab ein grund zu
wenig lehrerinnen und lehrer
denn eine instanz von über 50 haben
mittlerweile fast alle kommunen in nrw
mehrere eu staaten melden höchstwerte
bei der zahl der krone neuinfektion und
reagieren mit neuen beschränkungen in
frankreich gibt es mehr als 50.000
neuansteckungen etwa 17 prozent aller
corona tests sind positiv für zwei
drittel aller franzosen gilt eine
nächtliche ausgangssperre
italien meldet erstmals über 20.000 neue
fälle binnen 24 stunden bars und
restaurants müssen jetzt ab 18 uhr
schließen
fast genauso viele fälle im kleinen
belgien die kliniken melden überlastung
skifahren ohne gedränge oder hütten
gaudi wie soll das gehen in der pandemie
zum auftakt der skisaison sucht auch
österreich darauf eine antwort
das land kämpft vor allem um die
deutschen gäste 5,2 millionen waren es
in der vergangenen saison so viele kamen
nicht einmal aus österreich selbst
und jetzt also der große freiluft
versuch mit aufwändigen hygiene
konzepten auch in tirol wo fast jeder
vierte arbeitsplatz vom tourismus
abhängt alexander von sobeck lange
autoschlangen ins risikogebiet
zurückhaltend kontrolliert die polizei
die zufahrt den stubaital eine von acht
gletscher regionen in österreich
masken pflicht abstandsregeln disziplin
in den schlangen am skilift die meisten
finden es zwar lästig aber sie halten
sich daran
eigentlich funktioniert wirklich ganz
gut also an luft oder so ich hatte nicht
jeder mit der maske als basis sind ein
bisschen nervig halt dann die maßgenau
auf dem durch aber es war so dafür kann
man skifahren in anderen skigebieten wie
hier in kitzbühel fiel der auftakt der
skisaison mangels schnee ziemlich
verhalten aus kaum skifahrer auf den
wenigen kunstschnee pisten und in den
wintersportorten fürchten hoteliers
ladenbesitzer und wird das wetter
mindestens sowie die einschränkungen
durch die pandemie er bei uns ist die
situation im grunde genommen was das
hotel anbelangt prekär also da ist jetzt
wenig bis gar nichts habe freunde die
sie in der gastronomie freunde diesen
die hotels und es ist so viel schon
storniert worden
trübe aussichten also für die skisaison
2020 21
zumal rückkehrer aus österreichischen
risikogebieten nach 48 stunden
aufenthalt einen negativen test brauchen
oder in quarantäne müssen wen wundert's
dass einige da gerne an zeiten erinnern
als skifahren noch ein unbeschwertes
vergnügen war diffamierend und
inakzeptabel so nennt die
bundesregierung die jüngsten äußerungen
des türkischen präsidenten erdogan
der hatte den geisteszustand des
französischen präsidenten makro infrage
gestellt ihm eine hasskampagne gegen
muslime vorgeworfen und zum boykott
französischer barren aufgerufen
mack hatte mit scharfer kritik am
radikalen islam auf den islamistischen
mord an einem lehrer reagiert und die
mohammed-karikaturen verteidigt nach
belarus die opposition demonstriert die
regierung reagiert mit massenfestnahmen
so ist die situation seit wochen
jetzt haben die regime gegner innen zu
einem generalstreik aufgerufen es ist
eine kraftprobe
präsident lukaschenko will die
unternehmen um jeden preis offen halten
um zu demonstrieren dass er noch rück
in der bevölkerung hat die opposition
will zeigen dass eben das nicht stimmt
vergaberecht ist bei uns niemand im büro
sagt alexander
der 47 jährige besitzt einen design
studio in minsk seien rund 50
mitarbeiter und mitarbeiterinnen hat er
ermuntert am generalstreik der
opposition teilzunehmen
[Musik]
wir wollen was alle menschen wollen wie
menschen behandelt werden schon in einer
guten modernen gesellschaft leben und
nicht in einem konzentrationslager
großräumige schließt euch anrufen sie in
deutschland kühlschrank fabrik auch in
einigen anderen staatsbetrieben wird die
arbeit niedergelegt vor dem
traktorenwerk in minsk hat sich eine
handvoll demonstranten versammelt andere
fürchten die konsequenzen
wir streiken nicht wir arbeiten ich muss
ja irgendwie meine rechnungen bezahlen
fast die hälfte aller jobs in belarus
ist staatlich oder teil staatlich wir
gegen das regime aufbegehrt riskiert
viel lohn arbeitsplatz und persönliche
freiheit 220 protestierende werden laut
angaben von menschenrechtlern heute
festgenommen
wir haben keine angst mehr was soll
schon noch passieren
das land ist sowieso schon im chaos
versunken der plan der opposition
belarus lahmzulegen ist heute nicht
aufgegangen busse und bahnen fuhren die
meisten geschäfte blieben geöffnet
doch vor allem pensionierte und
studierende haben wieder demonstriert zu
tausenden und so gezeigt der wille der
wähler russen für demokratische
veränderungen zu kämpfen bleibt
ungebrochen zurück nach deutschland wo
viele die am morgen im rhein main gebiet
mit dem auto unterwegs waren jede menge
geduld mitbringen mussten von drei
brücken wie hier über der a3 nahe
wiesbaden hatten sich mehrere männer und
frauen abgeseilt um gegen den ausbau der
a 49 in mittelhessen zu protestieren
die polizei sperrte die autobahn bis sie
die aktion beendet hatte 30 ausbaugegner
wurden in gewahrsam genommen
wir kommen zum sport sehen mit einem
ungewöhnlichen erfolg in tennis das kann
man wohl sagen nach seinem sieg beim atp
turnier in köln vor acht tagen hat
alexanders wäre auch das zweite finale
dort gewonnen corona bedingt traten die
tennis profis gleich noch mal am selben
ort an
zweimal köln zweimal bitte recht
freundlich das turnier duell am rhein
hat alexander zverev sichtlich gut getan
von beginn an lässt der schwarzmann
keine chance 6 zu 2 im ersten satz wäre
zeigte sein ganzes potenzial gegen einen
gegner aus dem top ten der welt der
kleine argentinier ist gegen das harte
und präzise spiel des deutschen machtlos
mit einem ähnlichen vorhandschlag zum 6
zu 1 macht es wäre auf den klaren sieg
perfekt die beiden großen turniere in
paris und london zum jahresende können
kommen alexander zverev ist gerüstet
seit 15 jahren steuert christian seifert
als geschäftsführer die geschicke der
deutschen fußball liga heute verkündete
der 51 jährige überraschend seinen
rückzug zum sommer 2022 gerade für sein
corona krisen management hatte seifert
viel anerkennung bekommen und mit
richtig viel zuversicht geht der fc
bayern ins champions league duell mit
lok moskau nicht nur wegen der sechs
siege in den letzten sechs spielen
sondern auch weil es herrscht gabri
nach kurzer corona quarantäne nun doch
wieder zur mannschaft stoßen durfte
heute morgen war sie wieder dabei die
quarantäne aufgehoben vom gesundheitsamt
der positive test der eine einen irrtum
offensichtlich weil alle weiteren
negativ waren zwei zusätzliche ebenso
wie die normalen corona test so klar ist
mir irgendwie erschienen dass wir auch
irgendwann mal einen positiven test bei
uns da bayern so logisch ist auch dass
auch dort wo weiß nicht wie viele
tausend es täglich da reinkommen dass da
mal was schief gehen kann
seit der länderspielpause sind die
bayern wieder ganz die bayern
lewandowski traf allein in den letzten
beiden bundesliga spielen fünf mal nur
dazwischen in der champions league nicht
aber das kann sich am morgen in moskau
ändern wir sehen danke und wir schauen
noch kurz in den himmel nämlich zu sofia
im größten fliegenden infrarotteleskop
auch betrieben vom deutschen zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt
damit haben wissenschaftler jetzt
weiteres wasser auf dem mond
nachgewiesen einiges auch als eis
konserviert und das ist eine
vielversprechende nachricht für alle die
künftig eine mond-mission planen ja
schauer und gewitter dazu viel wind so
sehen die aussichten aus die details
gleich von westend herr li beim wetter
so viel von uns schön dass sie dabei
waren
im heute-journal freut sich bettina
schausten auf sie um 21.45 und wir sind
dann morgen wieder da punkt 19 uhr
schönen abend noch tschüss
[Musik]
ein schön gerahmt und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wechselhaft geht
es in den nächsten tagen weiter und auch
der kommenden nacht regnet es ja schon
im südosten deutschlands dieser regen
der verabschiedet sich langsam richtung
südosten
in den höheren lagen oberhalb von 1000
metern fällt noch schnee wird morgen im
tagesverlauf weniger und morgen dann von
westen neuer regen in der nacht also im
südosten dicht bewölkt mit regen
oberhalb von 1000 metern schnee sonst
sind einige schauer dabei in den
frühstunden von westen einzelne schauer
und auch ganz im norden einzelne schauer
meist bleibt es dazwischen aber trocken
und die temperaturen sinken auf null
grad an den alpen und 9 grad an der
neiße
morgen am vormittag im südosten noch
dicht bewölkt es wird langsam weniger
hier fällt auch noch etwas regen sonst
im tagesverlauf einige schauer im westen
die nach nordosten ziehen an der nordsee
auch gewitter möglich bei temperaturen
von bis zu 15 grad am oberrhein und 7
grad an den alpen sonst ganz im norden
an den küsten um die 12 grad
die kommenden tage gehen meist
wechselhaft weiter am mittwoch im süden
eher trocken bei 10 bis 16 grad im
norden sogar gewitter teils sehr windig
ab donnerstag kaum änderungen damit ein
schöner abend